foreign
[Music]
you finished scraping the gum off that
lounger or what all right
everything right now feels so Out Of
Reach you always land on your feet bro
you're hymen
Jenny
God that's your life but do not open it
you went in to get us jobs and all you
brought back was the hamburger
okay I don't think it's a burger you
haven't looked what the hell is that
how did you get it to do that I think he
likes me
[Applause]
look at me
almost acquired okay
foreign
it's some kind of world destroying a
weapon it's designed to protect the
toast
sometimes it does what you want and
sometimes it does it
I I think I cut a bus in half
Scarab chose you but it belongs to me
hello you feel for your family
makes you weak
[Music]
the universe has sent you a gift and you
have to figure out what you're going to
do with it
whatever you can imagine
I can create
[Music]
haha yeah
nice choice
oh it's like Batman stuff Batman's a
fascist
[Music]